- All right, Selena.
Selena where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Here in Manchester.
- And tell me about your family,
you had both your parents
growing up or do you have
both your parents currently?
- No.
- What do you mean?
- My mother, she's a drug
addict. She had four kids and
let us all get adopted
by parts of the family.
- Oh really? So you've been adopted?
- Yes.
- And how is your adopted family?
- My adopted family still..
how do I put this?
Hold on I'm sorry.
My adopted family is my family already.
But my aunt is no longer
my aunt. She's my mom.
- Oh I see, so your aunt became your mom?
- Yes.
- Okay I got it. And is your
biological mom still around?
- She's in and out. But when she's around,
she's not the best.
- Oh I see.
So how would you describe your childhood?
It seems like you're having
a nice happy childhood right?
- Yeah. But like when I was
little, you know, I would
go around my real mom but it just
wasn't good for me as being a little kid
seeing that growing up.
- Seeing what? The drugs?
- Yes.
- You know, I've interviewed
some other members of
your family and there seems like drugs are
pretty vivid.
- Plenty.
- All through clay
county there's drugs but
your families no exception.
So its all around you.
You're in high school right now?
- Yes.
- What year are you in high school?
- I'm in 11th grade.
- So you have one more year.
And how do you navigate
the fact that there are
drugs all over your house?
- I just try to stay away
from it the best I can.
For me, I don't see that as a lifestyle.
I see it as a choice that somebody makes
and its really broke my
family apart to be honest.
- Yeah, its very destructive.
- Yes
Do you have friends in school that are
playing around with drugs aw well?
- Yes.
- It seems like its pretty
prevalent here among the kids,
among the adults. Its like
almost every family gets
touched by it, it seems.
- Yeah.
- So how does that effect you when you go
to parties, when you
socialize? Stuff like that.
- I don't. I stay at the house.
The most I ever do is go
to one of my cousins house
or go to my boyfriends house
because I'm not the party type.
- So you're avoiding it all?
- Yeah.
- That's probably a smart move.
And what's your plan after school?
- After I graduate high
school, I'm going to the
nursing college in Hazard.
They have a very good
nursing college and
that's my main interest
right now. Its getting through school
and having a good life.
- Good for you. And your
long term plan would be
to get away from this region?
- Yeah. Like just to get
away from all the drugs.
I know its all over
the state but you know,
I can go on my own and not
have to have the choice
of either going down the wrong path
and messing my life life up.
Because its all I've ever been around
- Yeah. Yeah you've seen it first hand
- Yeah
- What the ending result is. Are any of
your family members working?
- No
- They're all just like
collecting money off
the government and
- Yeah. Buying drugs and stuff with it.
- Well its great that you're
steering clear of all that.
That's a beautiful thing for you.
How many kids would you say in your class
have the same attitude you do?
- About 50% of them.
- 50%, that's good.
And then what about uh,
you know college is expensive,
I don't know how much
money your family has.
- Yeah, um,
they have a thing in
the state of Kentucky.
If you're adopted, or in foster care,
you can go to college for free as long as
its in the state.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- So that will help you out?
- Yeah, a lot. Tremendously.
- That's a great thing.
- So I mean, do you,
how do you view this, this region?
You have lashes seem to be so affected
by drugs and unemployment.
- Yeah
- You see that, you are a smart
girl it seems. How do you..
Do you talk with your
friends about like what
the prospects are of staying here or
doing drugs or anything like that?
- Um, I've had a few friends
that already took their own path
but they finally got their way back.
And a lot of people getting on employment,
(indistinct chatter)
but sometimes they just want
to buy other stuff with it.
- How bad does it get in high school?
- There's..
- How serious is the drug problem I mean
- They even get to where they bring it
to school and sell it,
it's bad.
- In their families,
they have the same situation you do.
It's in their families, it's what they've,
it's the role models they've had.
What's been your favorite
memory in your 16 years?
- Having my little
niece and nephew around.
- Yeah, you have a couple
small, you have a sister
and a niece that uh,
- Um, I have a niece and a nephew.
- Oh, a nephew
- Yeah, and.
- This is your,
- She's my niece, my older sister had her
and her little brother Brandon
and her mother took the
same path as our real mother
because she wanted her attention
so bad when she was little.
- So your mom kind of takes
care of you, your niece
- And my nephew
- And your nephew, and you guys
are all obviously drug free
and avoiding everyone that is
is using right?
Good for you.
So what are the best and
the worst things about
living in that (inaudible)
- The uh, good thing is
like the scenery that you can
see all over like the fall
and I say about the only
bad thing going around here
is the drug usage
and all that like young kids to adults.
- Can you even envision staying here
and trying to find a job and all that
or is it's just hopeless?
- It's just hopeless.
- It's a shame coz it's such
a lovely part of the country.
- Yeah,
- But it's just been destroyed,
- Absolutely
- The lack of employment and drugs
and your mom must be very proud.
- Yeah, she is very ecstatic with me.
- Like you see people in
your family, I mean what..
They going through like depression
and jail time and all kinds
of stuff like this right?
- Yeah,
- So that's such a great
warning sign for you to just uh,
- Just steer clear
- Steer clear
You have the scare straight program
right in your own
living room.
- Yes
- What do you think of this life?
I mean, what do you think the
future is for (indistinct)
- I'd say if the people that
want help actually gets it
and sticks to it, this
could be an amazing place
but if they continue on the
path they're on there's no hope
for none of them.
- Yeah, and what do you think
the most important lesson
you've learnt in your 16 years has been?
- Don't do drugs, like that's it,
just don't do drugs no matter
how much you get peer pressured in
trying to do them just don't do it.
- That's a great one,
all right Selena,
well thank you so much
for sharing your story
- You're welcome
- And I wish you the
best of luck in college
and the rest of your life.
- Thank you
- You're on the right
track, I'm proud of you
- Thank you